alright let's get started hello everyone
first of all thanks for being here so
early yes I think it's the first talk
after the keynote so it's impressive
that you made it here after the party
last night if you've been there
my name is Matata Mel I'm a developer
advocate at Google I'm based in London
but I always try to come to and this is
also because I love this conference it's
one of my favorite conferences
maybe we realize we also Google cloud
has a booth at the entrance with cool
swag and and cold labs and we also have
a raffle at 1:00 p.m. for Google home
mini so feel free to stop by I'll be
there as well
today we I'm going to be talking about
Kay native this talk is designed for 40
minutes or so but we have one hour so
feel free to stop me at any time if you
have any questions I like this to be
interactive if possible but I can't
really see you so if you have a question
just yell so that I make sure that I see
you because these lights are right in my
face
and also one thing to mention these
slides and in the code it's already on
github so if you go to my github link
and this is the QR code everything is
already there so you don't have to keep
taking pictures this is the only feature
that you have to take before I start my
talk I always talk about Google cloud
for startups because I like to help help
startups so if you're part of a start-up
or if you are thinking about doing your
own startup just keep in mind that
Google cloud has a startup program where
you can get $3,000 $20,000 or $100,000
free credits if you're interested and
this is the link so if you go to this
link you can start with $3,000 free
credit if your startup is eligible I
always mention this because I I like the
idea of startups and I like to I like
you to know that we like to support
startups at Google cloud alright let's
get started with Kay native who will
hear her locatinator before or uses Kay
native okay so what I'm assuming here is
that you either know or use containers
and you either know or use something
like Cuban it is to manage your
containers and you're also interested in
in in server this world and running
server lists in your cubensis platform
so you probably heard okay native but
you don't know exactly what it is or
what it provides
and hopefully this talk will give you
all the introduction
so it's an intro-level talk but at the
same time we will go through a lot of
different parts of K native it's very
demo driven in at the beginning I'll do
a little bit of introduction with a few
slides but after that it will be very
much like that or even kind of talk and
as we go along as I mentioned feel free
to stop me and ask me any questions that
you have first of all what is KY native
k native it's Cuban it is based
open-source building blocks for server
lists and if you know anything about
Cuban it is you know that it doesn't
make sense to talk about Cuban it is a
server that's in the same sentence
because Cuban it is is it's all about
scheduling containers on actual nodes
right and these nodes are either virtual
machines or they're physical machines
but their servers and their service that
you have to think about and if you are
not using a managed platform like Google
kubernetes engine you need to think
about the immunity to maintain them so
there's nothing service about humanities
but that's the whole point okay native
ok native tries to make kubernetes that
server this platform and that's what I'm
gonna explain here today in this talk
now of course we need to define what we
mean my server list so depending on who
you talk to you get different
definitions of server lists some people
define it as functions and that's it and
some people define it as basically
anything that you don't have to maintain
a service for me when I think about an
ideal service framework first of all I
don't have to think about service
obviously oh there's a service somewhere
and someone has to maintain them but
ideally it shouldn't be my problem if
I'm using a service framework secondly I
like my service framework to be dramatic
for example I'm a signatu over so I'm
used to using s without my core web api
is so I should be able to use that in my
service framework or if you are a Java
person you should be able to use spring
boot because that's what you're used to
right so ideally you want your service
framework to support the tools and
languages that you're already using when
whenever we talk about service it's
usually event-driven so something usual
triggers your container or triggers your
function so it's kind of asynchronous
rather than synchronous and it's also
nice if the service framework is
portable
meaning if you deployed your server
dysfunction or your service container to
one platform like Google Cloud ideally
you should be able to take it and deploy
it to other places as well you shouldn't
have to rewrite at least too much to
move things around so Kay Nadeau I think
it does a pretty good job of supporting
all these features that I look in an
internet service framework now for those
of you who might not know Cuban it is
just a single slide to cover what
kubernetes is so Cuban it is is all
about scheduling and running containers
so what you do is you first define an
image for your code so your your your
code lives in a public repository like
docker hub or Google container registry
then from there you create what's called
a pod template apart it's the single
unit that gets scheduling in Cabana tees
it's usually a single container but can
be multiple containers scheduled
together as well then you tell Cubans to
want to be true in this case we want to
have three replicas of the spots so
competitors will look at your pod
template I will create three parts and
it will schedule them onto the nodes
that you have so these nodes are either
virtual machines or physical machines if
you are running equipment is locally
then once you're opposed to running can
label them and then you can group them
into what's called cumulative services
these services they have stable virtual
IPs and they can have domain names as
well and people from outside will get
your service and from there we'll get
your pods and your code running in the
pods
so in this container is kubernetes world
and my service ends up being a
combination of your code coupled with
what cubensis provides with replication
controller services parts and all that
kind of stuff
so cube Anytus is great for running
containers at scale because it provides
this high-level API and the framework to
run containers at scale but as
developers we don't care at least we
should we shouldn't care because when
you're a developer you're trying to
solve a business problem and you're
trying to write code to solve that
ideally all these details are what
running your code should be abstracted
away from you right so on one hand we
have developers who don't want to care
about this stuff on the other hand we
have operators who love commodities
because it provides this framework
and this eight this high-level API is to
manage containers so there's this
tension basically between developers and
operators and Knesset tries to solve
this tension so the whole point okay
NATO is that it tries to turn kubernetes
into a service platform so that the
developers using the platform they don't
have to care about the underlying
kubernetes but operators they can still
use kubernetes and they can still
enforce things that Cubana test helps
with so the que native is on github it's
an open source project it started from
Google but now a bunch of companies like
Red Hat an IBM NSA p.m. pivotal there
and many more they are supporting it by
the way maybe I should combine red had
an IBM into IBM now that I been bought
Red Hat but anyway it's a set of
components serving eventing and built
that will go through and it basically
came from Google like it so all the
things that we used and learn from
Google we kind of open search that in
Canada and for those of you who use
Google Cloud before if you use App
Engine you will see some of the concepts
of App Engine kind of bleeding in 2k
native like for example versioning and
traffic splitting stuff like that is
they are now open source on in turkette
native so some of the things that I was
used on App Engine I was pleasantly
surprised to see him in K native so the
K native stack it kind of looks like
this the underlying platform is Cuban it
is so you're running on Cuban it is on
top of that K native doesn't really deal
with the networking layer instead it
relies on a gateway by default it uses
sto as the Gateway to figure out the
traffic rules and all the traffic
details but in the latest version of
Candida which is 0.6
they added support for Glu anyone here
knows or users glue know a little bit ok
I don't know anything because I never
used it but apparently it's a
lightweight gateway so the thing about
East I said it's it's a great gateway it
provides a lot of features but it's kind
of heavy weight you need to have a feel
like for example if you want to run
cuban it is a nice deal in Google Cloud
you probably need at least three or four
nodes so because of that some people
find a little bit heavy weight and
their support for glue which is
supposedly much more lightweight than
steel but the thing about glue is that
it if you use glue with kn8 if it
doesn't support kinetic eventing yet so
you need to keep that in mind
so either way so you have your cabinet
is running you have your networking
handled by steel or glue and on top of
that you installed Kay native so Kay
native has three parts built serving and
eventing you can install them separately
like one by one or you can install them
all at once if you want so you don't
have to use them all at once it's
basically up to you to pick and choose
which part you want and then on top of
that there's there are products that are
being built on top of Kay native for
example on Google Cloud there's
something called Google Club run which
is a manager original Kay native on
Google Cloud there's something called
Google run on gke which is the manager
version of Kay native but on google
kubernetes engine so if you want to stay
in queue but it is eco system you can
still use Google Cloud run on gke and
there's other products from other
companies that are being built on top of
Kay native so the idea is that you use
Kay native as the underlying platform
but then you would for the developer
experience you'll use the product from
the company that you're using so if
you're on Google Cloud it probably makes
sense to use google run because it's
much more managed and much more
user-friendly than using K native itself
but this talks is is about K native so
I'll show you how to install K NATO and
have to run K native as if you're doing
it yourself and I'll show a small demo
Google run so that you get an idea of
the developer experience on Google cloud
run as well okay so how do you use K
NATO first of all you need a kubernetes
cluster so depending on where you are
you there's different ways of setting
about this cluster but on Google cloud
you would use a g-cloud command line
tool to create a cluster so here I'm
saying I want to create a cluster this
is my name of the cluster and I'm saying
that I want add-ons and one of the atoms
is Sto so when I create my cluster SEO
will also be installed for me with this
way I don't have to install it
separately and then I specify some
things like the Machine type and the
cluster version and this zone where I
want my cluster so eventually I have a
cluster so this is a typical
kubernetes cluster with a steward
install
and then I need to create a cluster role
binding so that K native and East you
can manage the traffic within my cluster
so that's what the cluster well biting
is all about and then after that you
install k native so in this case I am
using zero point six point zero which is
the latest version of K native and it
comes with the llamo files for it so if
you want to install serving you would
point the server llamo file if you want
to install built you would point two
billion file so this is how it would be
solve the full version of K later but
you can also pick and choose parts of
Kenya them and install just those as
well so in the end what you'll end up
having is let me show you my console so
here I mean Google Cloud console I
already created a GK equal go
comparators engine cluster I already
have it installed I already have have
quenette installed as well and just to
make sure that things are working I can
go and say keep CTL get pods and then
everything gets installed under separate
namespaces so here I'm saying let me
look at the pods okay native serving
namespace and let's make sure that
they're running so they are and then
let's look at K native eventing tones
are running as well and then let's look
at a native built so those are running
as well so everything is running so we
can actually proceed with our
presentation and then look at the demos
later so let's first talk about the
first part okay native K native serving
so what is K that is serving it
basically enables you to deploy a
container in a server this way
that's how explain it and what I mean by
that is you basically create a service
definition file for your creative
service and you point your container
that you want to deploy and then what
can it does is that it deploys a
container it sets up all the traffic to
the container so all the traffic details
will help people get to your content is
already set up because we still and then
by default your container will run on a
single pot but it will automatically
scale up and down so if no one uses it
within 60 seconds it will scale down to
0 if more people use it then it will
scale up to n that you define so you
have automatic scaling then every time
you deploy your container
you get a new revision so you will have
a new revision every single time and
with that revision you also have
configuration for each revision and then
once you have the religions by default
each revision will get all the traffic
but you can set rules so that you can do
traffic splitting so you can do things
like you know the latest version gets
50% of traffic the newest version gets
the other 50% as well so basically it
enables you to deploy a container and
get traffic set up to the container get
auto scaling set up for the container
get revision management and get traffic
splitting between those revision
management's right so that's what cane a
disturbing is in a nutshell and the
terminology okay can it disturbing I
already explained this a little bit just
to go over again at the top level you
define a cane a to service this is not a
kubernetes service by the way it's que
native service and your service will
have a configuration where you point
your image and you also have some
configuration like environment variables
for your container and things like that
and once you deploy your service with
its configuration it will create a
revision for your service and it will
create a route that points to that
revision so by default the latest
revision we will get all the traffic now
if you change anything about the
configuration here like changing the
image or changing the amount variable it
will create a new revision and it will
point the route to that revision right
but you can also set rules here in the
middle here so they can do traffic
splitting so the primitives okay native
serving is that service configuration
revision and route that points to the
revision that you want so let's take a
look at some of examples of this as I
mentioned all of this is on my github as
kn8 tutorial and I will refer to this
tutorial as we go along so first I want
to show you the hello world example so
we get an understanding of how that
looks like by the way all my samples are
extremely simple because I want I always
try to find the simplest example that I
can show you to get the point across
because sometimes you see some examples
where it's like too complicated and
you're trying to understand what's
happening so for that reason I keep my
examples really simple so what I'm doing
here is that I'm writing a simple
c-sharp hello world application that
will just when it gets a request it will
read an emirate variable
and it would just echo back and say
hello world with that so I create the
service I won't show you the code
because it's really simple just as hello
world
then I built an image and push it to
docker hub and then what we need to do
is we need to create a service Yama file
so this is the service definition for my
create a service
the first thing that you're gonna
realize is that this is the API this is
the que native API and the type is
service then you give yourselves a name
and you define which the namespace this
service should live in so in this case
it's default name service and then you
define the configuration of your service
first here we are saying run latest what
this means is that when I deploy this
service it will get all of the traffic
it will get 100% of the traffic and then
under the under the configuration we
point to the image that we pushed so it
points to my image and on docker hub and
then I am also passing their moment
variable with the name target and the
values of v1 so it will read this target
and my variable and it will just say
hello world
v1 so that's what my service does so we
will apply the service and then we'll
look at the part the que native service
the kinetic configuration the Canadian
revision and the kanay to route as we
create things so let's do that so let me
first watch things bigger you'll realize
that I have some pods running these are
for pods that will read some events
later that I'm gonna show you so you can
ignore them for now they're not relevant
for this example but I created them
because it takes a little bit of time to
create them for the next example but
here I am in hello world section and
then I have a bunch of service
definition ones and I want to apply the
first one so let's apply service v1 so
this creates a hello world service and
you'll realize that immediately we have
a pod that's been created that's already
running we have a cognitive service
that's been created we have a
configuration for the service we have a
revision which is the first version of
the revision and we also have a route
that's pointing to the revision so
everything is already up and running but
how do we get to the service right we
need to go through steel because it's
the one managing the the traffic to the
cluster and in east yo there's something
called it's your gateway
he still gateways basically
an external IP that manages all the
traffic into the cluster so we need to
find this your ingress gateway and then
we need to curl to that IP but we need
to specify which service we want to get
to right because you can have multiple
services on the same IP so in this case
I'm saying I want to get to the hello
world service in the default namespace
and this example comm is the default
domain in a native so that's how you
could get to your service if you haven't
configured your own domain now in the
next section on my tutorial I show you
how to setup the domain I won't bore you
with the details and for them or what I
did is that I use something called knit
dot IO knitted IO it's a dummy domain
service that enables you to basically
map things like this like ten point zero
point zero zero point one if that IO
maps to an and IP so I use this as my
domain service so that I don't have to
set up a real domain and once I did that
and I explained how to do this here you
can do a curl like this as if I have a
domain and let's go back here and do a
curl and you said that it says you see
that it says have a v1 so our service is
running right so basically deploying a
container is just like a service llamo
just deploy and everything is set up for
me now every time I change something
about the service it creates a new
revision for example let's say we want
to change the environment variable so
here instead of saying target and the
values v1 let's say we say v2 we change
that once we do that let's do it and see
what happens so I'm applying the version
two you will see that it immediately
creates a new revision so this is the
second revision and then it immediate
with pot so now I have two different
pods running and you updated the
configuration I sorry the route we don't
see the route here but let me see make
it bigger so the route well it's done
here but the rad is updated to the
latest revision and if i do a curl to
the same URL perry says he'll veto so we
updated our you know service with the
new configuration now if you want to
update the code it's the same way
so the code updates basically i I
changed my code and instead of saying
hello let's say I want to say bye
right now I changed my code I created a
new image now this image is version 3
instead of version 1 then I come to my
configuration and in the configuration I
changed my image instead of saying v1
now I point to version 3 image and apply
the service and let's do that so once I
do that again this will create now one
thing to realize that one of the pods is
terminating because it's the first
revision that we haven't used in the
last 60 seconds and because of that is
scaling down to zero right so the it
does auto scaling form automatically so
a version 1 is scaling down to 0 version
2 is running and version 3 with the code
changes running as well and now you can
see that I had three revisions and if I
do a curl to the same URL now it says by
v3 so we updated our code right but as
you know in the real world you wouldn't
update code just like that what you
would do is that you would maybe deploy
a new revision and maybe let it get say
20% of the traffic and see if it works
and if it works then you would gradual
scale up to 100% so you want to do like
red-green deployments or traffic
splitting or whatever you want to call
it you can do that in Kenya ETF what you
need to do for that is you need to go to
your service and instead of doing run
latest because we were doing run latest
which means it will get all the traffic
by default instead of that we'll do a
release I mean this release we will
refer to some revision so in this case
we're saying I want to do a release with
region 1 and region 4 and I want the
revision for to get 20% of the traffic
so this is what this means so the
revision 1 is the one that has already
deployed revision 4 is the one that I
want to deploy here and this 20 is the
20% is for this new revision and this
configuration here is the configuration
of this new revision it's a little bit
confusing and they're making this a bit
easier but for now this is what you need
to do this the configuration is for the
new revision the robot person is for the
new revision and this is for the old
provision so if you do this let's do
that
oh and then one thing I forgot is that
if you look at our revision numbers
they're not actually 1 or 4 there are
more like hash codes so I need to
actually do a proper release with this
proper name so I should copy this and
come back here instead of 1 let's make
this the proper name and then for the
4th let's copy this one and then do this
one now if I apply it it should update
my revisions and my traffic and let's do
some curl commands so let's do a loop
here so that you can see traffic
splitting so I'm doing here a loop or
curl like 10 times and let's see what
happens now you see that there's content
creating so it's probably hitting
version 1 and now it's version 4
it's version 1 version 4 version 4 it
looks like it's 50% but now it's mostly
version 1 yeah so most of the times it
should be warm 1 which is the case now
so we did like 80 percent to 20 percent
traffic splitting between an existing
revision and a new revision right now if
you want to do traffic splitting where's
my between two existing revisions you
can do that as well so you come to your
service and then in the revisions you
basically point to the revisions that
you already deployed and once we apply
this it will just do traffic splitting
like 50% traffic splitting between the
existing regions that you have so that's
how you can do traffic splitting inka
native now this auto scaling you're
scaling down to 0 and scaling up to n
it's all configurable and the actual
auto scaling type is also configurable
so let me show you how how that works
but before I do that let me deploy a
service and let's try let's try to load
the service and in the meantime I'll
explain your auto scaling and then we
can come to our service and see that
it's actually also scaled so what I'm
doing is that I created a new service
called asleeping service because it just
gets a request and sleeps for 4 seconds
like simulating traffic like doing some
work and then what I'm gonna do is that
I'm gonna change auto scaling so that it
doesn't so it will have concurrency
one and then we'll hit this service and
we'll see that it will scale up to five
but before I explain it let me just
deploy this and also copy the get this
4000 load so let's copy this and let's
go to sleeping service and then first of
all let me delete my hello world service
so as you can see once I delete it
everything is gone and these are
terminating already now let's apply the
sleeping service so now the sleeping
service is created and now let's try to
load this service send some traffic to
so I'm gonna use a tool called for tio
which is a load testing tool and I'm
just gonna send some traffic to that so
we'll just let that run as you can see
right now there's only one pod running
but hopefully when I come back it will
scale up to five that I said is the
maximum but in the meantime I can
explain you the auto scaling
configuration so the configuration water
scaling is basically it's under service
and then by default this is the auto
scaling configuration that you have so
the class auto scaling is sorry the
metric on water scaling is concurrency
meaning each part will get 100 is one
here but the default is hundred you will
get 100 requests before it scales up
right that's the default you can change
this number so in this case for my
sleeping service I change it to 1
meaning I only have one request coming
in coming in and then it will scale up
so that I can show your scaling but this
is configurable and also the type of
other scaling is configurable so if you
don't want to do concurrency a bit sort
of scaling but you need to do CPU by
sort of scaling you just comment this
out and then you just comment this in
the CPU and they will do CPU best of the
skin this is based on cube and the
kubernetes is CPU base of the scaling
the minimum and the maximum is also
configurable by default minimum scale is
0 meaning your pod will scale down to 0
if no one uses it in 60 seconds but you
can set it to 1 and that way you will
always have one pod running no matter
what and you can also set two
max in this case I set it to 5 so that I
won't have more than 5 pots running at
at all times and also this auto scaling
is also configurable in the sense that
you can write your own scaler and you
can plug into your to scale here as well
so you can write code to do what is
coming your way
if this doesn't work for you so that's
how you can do auto scaling and so we
deployed our sleeping service we are
loading it and if everything works yeah
as you can see we have five sleeping
services running because the four tiers
is loading them so let me just stop it
now
and then within a few SEC but not a few
seconds but within a minute or so these
sleeping services will scale down to
zero
okay so that's also scaling and also the
nice thing about K native is that you
can actually integrate with anything you
want because in the end you have a
container with a public URL and anyone
who can call that URL can get your
container so what I did is that I really
like Twilio anyone here heard of you or
use this video for anything yeah so 2004
those of you who might not know it's a
it's a framework it's a service to write
write phone or SMS applications and what
you can do is you can get a phone number
from Tullio at least in the UK you can
get get it for free and then you can say
when someone calls me on this number
make a call to this endpoint when
someone sends me a text on that number
make a call to this endpoint so what I
did is that I got Twitter number so this
is my UK number into yeah feel free to
call this number or text it if you want
because I'm not gonna be the one
answering it it will be K native who's
gonna answer it but basically once you
have this number you can say if someone
calls me call this endpoint I didn't
change this is to your default endpoint
and then if someone sends me a message
call this endpoint now in this case you
can see that I'm calling my dummy nib IO
endpoint and its / SMS so it's gonna
call my SMS controller that I deployed
and then just to give you an idea how
this looks like it's something very
simple I mean I created the hello world
app in s block net and then in here I
created an SMS controller
I'm using two Leos Newgate libraries and
I'm saying when someone calls me on this
end point / SMS create a response and
then just say que native copycat says
and then just reply back with the
message so basically I'll receive the
message and I'll just say I'll just
reply back with that message so that's
all it takes to reply back 20 SMS then I
create a docker file then I push it to
docker hub in here then I create my
service definition file just like before
but in snow I'm pointing to my Tulio
image and then I buy my service and
let's see what happens actually
so let's by the way you can see that my
sleeping service is scaled down to zero
so let's just delete that to fleet
alright and now let's go to 2000 by the
service now this should create my
Twitter service hopefully and then it's
running then I can go to my these are my
messages on my phone you can see my
messages and this is my Twitter number
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say
hello from NDC Oslo so I'm sending a
message from my phone to my Twilio
number this will go to Twilio Twitter
will make a call to my Kenny to endpoint
my Canadian point will wake up it will
hopefully yes it will say the K native
copycat says hello from in this also
will get the message right back and then
when no one replies back then no one
sends a message for 60 seconds it will
scale down to zero so you can see that
you can pretty much integrate with
anything you want because it's it's
basically in the end a public endpoint
that you can use all right let's see if
I want to show anything else with Kenny
to serving oh yeah and one thing that I
want to show is that so far what I've
shown you is K native everywhere so
every time you have kubernetes cluster
whether it's running locally whether
it's running on Google Cloud or adjure
you can have all
this so far but if you are on Google
cloud you would use something called
Google called run which is the manager
version ok native so what I want to do
is I want to show you here the user
experience with Google cloud run so that
you got an idea of how that works on
Google cloud so the thing about Google
cloud run is that it says something that
we just announced recently like a couple
months ago and because of that it's only
available in US central but it will be
available everywhere pretty soon so
first of what I need to do is I need to
switch to my project in US central let
me do that before I forget and then the
second thing I need to do is that Google
cut run doesn't support docker hub yet
it will so because of that I need to
submit my image to Google container
registry
it's like docker hub but it's for Google
Google cloud projects so what I'm doing
here is that I'm I'm running this
g-cloud command line and I'm saying this
is my submit my build
so this basically submits a build job it
builds the image in the cloud and it
says this image in Google container
registry right so that's what this
command does so I did that already and
once I have my image then I'm gonna run
this command to deploy to card run so I
will change the project ID to my ID run
tomorrow so what I'm saying is that
basically g-cloud is the command-line
tool for google cloud better is because
it's better and then run is means deploy
to Google cloud run and then I'm just
pointing to my image on Google container
registry that I pushed already so once
we do that it says ok the service name
is our world
yes and then it will create a revision
and it will read traffic to it just like
Canada right just like what I show you
it does the same thing crazy new
revision it was traffic to it but I
haven't created a cluster I haven't
created
I haven't installed eesti oh I haven't
set up cluster wall binding I haven't
done anything oh that is just deploy
this and it just deploy so for me it's
fully managed and once this is done it's
already done we can actually go to
Google Cloud console and I will switch
my project to cut run at the mount so
this is my project in US central and
then if we go to quad run
you see I have some projects here but
the hello world is the one that we just
deployed and you see on the revisions so
you got a console about for your
application and you can see that on the
revisions these are the ones that I
deployed and you can see that there's
one that was just deployed now so it's
the one that we just deployed and it's
getting a hundred percent of traffic we
can look at the logs if we want we can
well if it loads usually it's fast but
it's in the u.s. yes you can see the
logs so you can see my app is way
loosen one port 8080 you can look at the
metrics so if someone calls your app you
can see it here so you get all this by
default by just deploying it on quad run
you also get a URL so you don't have to
configure domain by default you can also
setup your domain with cloud run as well
but by default it gives a dummy domain
and if we click on it it won't be
anything exciting it will just say hello
we want just like before but it's
running a managed quad run so it's very
similar to a native except you don't
have to even think about the fact that
there is a cluster underneath right so I
just want to show you that quickly so
that you got an idea how that works so
now I can switch back to Mike a native
project and go back here and then let me
switch back here as well before I forget
because one time I forgot and it was a
disaster after four it's alright alright
so this I show you Twilio I show you
Claude round so we can skip that
so that's kinda disturbing next I want
to talk about ket eventing and in a
nutshell kinetic eventing basically
allows you to connect event sources to
event consumers with some kind of flow
in the middle I know this is a very
high-level description but that's
basically what it is the event consumers
are KNAT services and then you can do
some kind of filtering beforehand that
I'll talk about and the event sources
are basically a full list of things so
these this is not the full list the full
list is here but you can basically
listen things like Apache Kafka
you can listen Google Cloud pops up
messages you can listen github messages
you can listen Google Cloud storage
messages you can listen kubernetes
events so there's a lot of things they
can listen to and you can write your
listener if you want to but in the end
this is how it works so you have in
Canada you have something called K
native source this the thing that
listens the external event so for
example if you are listening Google
Cloud pops up it will listen pops up
messages so you set up a source that
listens the external event then it
passes to something called broker so in
the normal case you would have a broker
per namespace so in your namespace you
have a broker waiting for messages so
the source will listen the message it
will pass it to broker and the broker
will pass it to something called trigger
the trigger is the thing that makes the
connection between the broker and the
knh a service so eventually your your
message will end up in the service but
the trigger in the middle will do some
filtering if you want so it will for
example in the service it only wants to
care about this kind of message so it
will filter those messages and want to
pass those messages or not maybe you
don't want to do any filtering you can
just pass in every messages to service
but at the high level basically the
source listens for the message the
broker gets it for the namespace and
passes to the service via the trigger
though so the events in cognitive they
end up into something called cloud
events because these events you know
they can be any kind of events right
they can be github events or they can be
Google Cloud storage events but what
happens is that when it gets into que
native the que native source will take
those events and it will convert into
something called cloud events these are
the Khedive and it says it's an open
source ncf definition of events and it
has some metadata like the ID and the
time and stuff like that and data of
this card event will include will have
the actual event that you're interested
in so in this case for example we have a
github event so the data will include I
feel happy event but eventually
everything will be a cloudy event and
we'll go through broker and from broker
onwards it will all be quite events and
as I mentioned the Booker is the one
that gets the event for the namespace
and then from the broker it goes to
trigger the trigger does some filtering
if you want and then it will pass it to
a key native service that you define and
that's it that's all you have to do with
it and I'm gonna show you another
example
but let's do a hello world example again
so for example let's say we want to
deploy an eventing example to listen
Google Club pops up message so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna listen a
pop subtopic and get that event in 2k
native and then get that rather to and
Kenny to service and just log out the so
that message right do something simple
like just log it out how do we set that
up first what you need to do is you need
to make sure the creative anything is
set up so we already have that you need
to set up a source that reads the
messages right so in this case we want
to read pops up messages so we need to
set up a DCP pops up source I already
set that up but let's make sure that
it's running and lets me also go to
eventing part alright so maybe I do it
here soda pops up source this testing
source I already set up that's listening
or an external Google Cloud pops up
topic it's already running and we also
want to make sure that our default
namespace where I'm gonna run this
example has a broker waiting for the
messages so if I do keep CTL get broker
hopefully or they have that yeah and
actually if I do keep CTL get pods
you will see that I have a couple of
pots for broker that's already running
and another pot for the source that's
already running so these are the pods
that are listening for the events so
that's that's why we have them running
and actually I can also get rid of my
service that I don't need anymore
keep still delete get the service let's
just do it all yeah that gets really
want so the stuff is set up then what I
want to do is I need to create a
connected service to actually log out
the message so the service just to let
you know kind of looks like this what it
does is that it it's very simple when it
gets a message it just says the message
dumper we see the message and it just
logs out the content right it just locks
it out I create a docker file and then
what I need to do is I need to create a
Yama file for my trigger and for my
service so
I push my message and then in this
trigger llamo file I do a couple of
things the first thing is my service so
just like before I create a service with
the image and the minimum scale set it
to one so that I have I always have one
running and then the trigger in this
case I am NOT doing any filtering so any
message that will get into my broker
will go to my service but I the trigger
is used to combine my broker with my
service so that's how I do the
connection right so once we apply this
let's apply a certain number keep CTO
apply trigger let's clear this so that
that created the service and the trigger
and actually if you look at it keep CTL
get Potts you will see that I have a
message already running waiting for
messages and what I want to do is I want
to look at the logs of this part so
let's just copy this so that we can look
at the logs and copied that so you can
see that my app is just waiting for
messages on port a right it's just like
a native service now to trigger this I
need to send a message to Google pops up
topic and get that triggered the trigger
that pops up message and that will go to
que native and then KNAT will do the
full chain so let's do that so to do
that I can use g-cloud so I'll just copy
this so what I'm doing here is that I'm
saying g-cloud pops up topic publish and
then the the the place I'm publishing to
is called testing that's my topic and
the messages have evolved something very
simple so we do this and now this goes
to Google app pops up and then from
there makes it to que Nader you can see
that here it says message dump receipt
message ID and data right you don't see
hello world
well because this is a cloudy event
everything gets converted into a cloud
event and the data is the one that
actually contains the message so if I
take this this is base64 encoded and if
I do I think if I remember correctly
base the
and base64 HD maybe yeah you see that if
I die code it I say hello world so I you
see the message so that's how you make a
connection from an external system to a
KNAT service running in can native now
the next example I want to show you is a
it's a little bit more interesting what
I want to do is I want to combine Google
Cloud Storage to Google cloud vision API
so these are two separate things they'll
have nothing to do with each other but
you can use the loosely coupled
infrastructure ok native to combine them
so what I want to do is that in Google
Cloud Storage it's a place where you can
store any kind of files so I have a
bucket fork a native I create a bucket
fork a native and you can enable
notifications from the bucket so what I
did is that I created a bucket to save
some images then once I save an image to
the bucket it will it will send a
message to a pop subtopic that I define
and then I I have K native eventing lost
in the topic it will get that message
and it will pass it to akkanee to
service and the ki native service will
say ok I receive this message that said
that tells me that this there's an image
that's saved to this bucket let me call
the vision API which which is a machine
learning API to analyze this image and
extract labels out of this image and it
will just log it out to the user right
so that's the flow that I want to set up
to do this by the way I have another
example with translation API but we
don't have time for that so I'll skip
that but feel free to look at it if you
want so in the vision API first I need
to create the actual service that will
do the vision API call so what we do in
here is that first my code has to handle
cloudy events right eventually the
service will get cut events so I do some
parsing of the cloud events here we
don't have to get into details of that
but basically in the end you get a cloud
event and then I need to look at the
right cloud events right when you save
an image the type of the cloud event is
called object finalize so I'm just
looking at those events that have the
type object finalized and then from the
car event I can extract the bucket ID so
which bucket this image lives and the
object idea what's the name of this
image so I'm basically extracting those
and that gives me the
of this image in Google Cloud storage
then I can call vision API so to call
vision API I call a I create a vision
client so this is the kind I used to
make the vision API call and then I say
vision client detect labels async so
this says basically you know given this
image URL extract the labels out of this
image and give me ten results because I
don't care more than ten and then I will
have some labels with some scores
because it's using machine learning so
it's not 100% sure I take these labels I
order them by the score and I just lock
them out right so that's my code I
create a docker file and then I create a
let me show you that I create a trigger
Domino like before with the service that
points to my code and then the trigger
that connects broker to my service just
like before and let's actually deploy
this and see if we see what happens
and by the way this is how you create a
bucket and this is how you enable a
notification on the bucket but we don't
have to get into details of that so let
me go to vision and clear this cube CTL
apply trigger and if you do keep CTL get
pods so you see that it created my
service and the trigger and if you look
at the pods you see that I have my
vision pod running as well let's look at
the logs just like before at this time
instead of a message dumper I want to
look at the vision it's it's still
creating so hopefully it will be created
now yeah so it's waiting for messages
now what we want to do is I go to Google
Cloud I go to cloud storage I already
created a bucket for Mike a native
project and I already enabled
notifications on it so the bucket is
empty so let's just upload a file and
see what happens so I go upload files
and might find my tutorial eventing
vision pictures let's send this picture
I don't know if you can see this but
it's basically a nice beach with sunset
anyway guess is where this is
anyone know Spain no Mexico close but no
Chile Argentina close but no it's a real
in Brazil so I open this know how this
is being uploaded to a bucket in Google
Cloud storage that will trigger a pops
up message to a topic and Canada will
get that message and it will pass it to
Canada to service and from Canada so
make a call to vision API so if
everything worked which is a big if how
it worked
so we our code received the the cloudy
event the data is basically four encoded
from there the extracts the actual
message and then it makes a call to
vision API and in the end it says this
pictures labelled sky border water scene
nature cause water sunset horizon which
is pretty good but the point here is
very simple example but the point is
that you're connecting something like a
storage event to a machine-learning call
using K native in the middle and the
fact that I mean the fact that this K
native it lives in Google Cloud right
now but it can live anywhere you have
kubernetes and that's the important part
all right in the last 10 minutes or so I
want to cover Kenny to build the boring
part ok native that we all need you know
that's why I talked about in the in the
end soak a native build before I start
talking let me start some builds and
then we can talk about it as the builds
are happening that way we can look at
some bills afterwards so what I want to
do is uh let's kill this and let me know
I don't want that
so let's go to built and then I have
some bills here let me just kick some
bills and I'll explain what they're so
the first one is built HelloWorld GCR so
this builds and pushes an image to
Google container registry the second one
is a hello world to docker hub so it
will build and push an image to docker
hub the third one is it uses a build
template with Kaneko and pushes to
Google container registry and the other
one is a build template with build pack
which I really like it builds a Java app
and pushes to Google container registry
I think that's enough and then if you do
keep CTL get built you see that we have
four builds that are pending because
they're running so once I explained it
hopefully they will be done and I can
show you what they did so can you build
it basically enables you to go from
source code to an image in a repository
in a nutshell that's what it does and it
gives you some primitives to work with
so you would start with a built object--
a bill object it's basically one or more
steps that you define and they're
executed in that order
you can use what's called build
templates so you can take your build and
create a template out of it and and that
way you can use it from multiple bills
if you want or you can install someone
else's build template and use it from
your bills as well and and Kay native
comes with some build templates by
default and I'll show you one an example
of that that you can install and use it
it's very useful you have different
kinds of builders to build different
kinds of things like containers and you
if you need to authenticate you can use
a service account in your builds that
way you can push to places like docker
hub where you need identification so
that's what it is in a nutshell and just
to show you the examples that I kicked
off so if we go to hello world build so
in this one what I'm doing is that I am
creating a built so the kind is built
and this is my this is the name of my
build you point your source so the
source in this case is that I'm building
my can a tutorial the hello world
example and then I then you define your
steps
in your build I only have one set here
it's called build and push and I'm using
something called koneko koneko it's an
open source image builder that you can
use in your communities cluster so
basically it you can use Kanika and it
creates a pod that will build the image
and push it to wherever you want so in
this case I'm just pointing to koneko
image and then I'm pointing to my chakra
file and then the destination is where
you tell to push so in this case it's
GCR dot IO meaning Google container
registry so this will build it and then
it will push it to Google container
registry and then once you you can look
at the build and you can look at the
pods actually if you look at the pods
you will see that there will be there
will be some parts for the bills that we
are having and some of them are in it
meaning they are running and completely
is the one that's actually finished so
that's a hello world built and in the
end once this is done I will show you
there is a you can go to Google
container registry also this is pushed
if you need to push somewhere like
docker hub you need to authenticate and
for that you need to create user service
account so to do that first you need to
create a secret so see it's a kubernetes
construct where you specify your
username and password basics Devorah
encoded and and then from secret you
create what's called a service account
again another communities construct the
service account has a name and it also
points to the secret that you just
created so you apply both the secret and
service account so that's that creates
the service account with it with the
secret and then when you design your
built it just like before the I mean
this bill is exactly the same as before
except I have a service account name
here so now I am referring to the
service account that I that I just
creating increment it is and this will
authenticate me with docker hub and the
other thing that's different is the
destination so the destination here is
not GCR that I always talk with a a oh
so that's how you can push things to
docker hub now the next one I want to
show is a build template so right now we
define our steps manually right but you
normally don't do that what you do is
you either create a template or you use
someone else's template for example
within
using koneko to build our images instead
you can actually install Kanaka build
template there's a template that's
already out there and you can just
install using this and then in the end
once you have the temple you can take a
look at it by just saying cube city I'll
get built template and see which temples
you have so once you have this template
in your cluster what you can do is you
can go to your build and you still point
your code and everything and give it a
name just like before but instead of
doing these steps manually you here you
just point to a template so in this case
I'm pointing to the caracal template and
the Kanaka template it asks me where do
you want to push this image so that's
the name image and the value is a Google
container registry so that's how you
could use a template from your built so
the rest is pretty much the same and the
very last thing that I wanna mention is
the build tax anyone here heard over
users build packs no oh cool so bill
packs I think they're really cool
because I don't know you but at least
for me creating an optimized docker file
is quite challenging because you need to
kind of be a docker expert to be able to
figure out what you should use how and
in what order and what you should put in
your container all that kind of stuff
what bill packs do is it's an open
source project
it's basically looks at your code and it
tries to create any image out of your
code without you having to create a
docker file right so you don't have to
worry about creating finally build pack
does that for you that's the whole point
of the project and the cool thing about
Kay native is that there's a template
for Bill pack that you can install so
you can install the build pack template
like this and then in your build when
you build your source so in this case
I'm building a java application right in
this java application if you go to there
you'll see there's no local file just a
plain Java code and then I'm pointing to
my template build pack template and I'm
just saying push this to Google
container registry what it will do is
that it will use build pack to detect my
code and it will create I guess it will
create a doctor file for it for me and
it will push it to Google container
registry without me having to worry
about dokkan files myself which I like
because I don't want to deal with all
the complexities of docker myself
so that that's that's what we do here
and very last thing is that if you want
to set up your testing so that you have
a service and every time you change your
service it kicks up built and builds it
and deploys your service you can do that
I won't explain it here but basically I
show you how to do it here so automatic
deploys are possible as well so if
everything worked let's take a look if
you look at pods they are all completed
if you look at builds they are all
succeeded and just to prove that they
actually worked let's go to Google
container registry and this is hello
world app you can see that this was
pushed two minutes ago by Kaneko so this
is the chemical template and this was
pushed three minutes ago I built so that
was the first sample and if you look at
docker hub under hello world hopefully
that worked as well you can see the
hello world and it's hard to see but
this was sent by built four minutes ago
all right I think let's see if I have
anything else yeah I think that's all I
have
thanks for listening if you want the
slides and the code and much more than
what I showed here it's on Canada
tutorial and this is a QR code Kay
native has a new page Canetti dev which
with more informational samples and I
think we have like four minutes for
questions so I can I guess I can take
like one or two questions if you have
any thanks very much so any questions
before I go anyone no fun - all right
yes
not yet but it will be available like
really soon because we are also testing
it basically yes you'll see it on the
webpage soon like there's no like
private sign up or anything like that
right now yeah alright if you I'm gonna
bet the Google cloud booth so feel free
to stop by if you have any other
questions there thank you